they're now ready to be anointed from
their basement bunkers
they can't hide they're going to
campaign no they're not apparently
they're not going to meet with the
voters they certainly aren't going to
answer any questions from their adoring
cult fans and propaganda wing
that would be the mob in the media take
a look
what do you think about that
okay guys let's go let's go fun
okay let's go you guys come on let's go
come on guys let's go you guys let's go
all right senior washington
correspondent jeff zeleny is joining me
now
a couple notes jeff one not a whole lot
of questions from reporters there i mean
we keep pressing the biting campaign
there needs to be more questions from
reporters we know that
yeah uh maybe two pressers with
oh in the teleprompter i'm supposed to
go to joe now
uh yeah in a hundred and like 40 days
two really are they going to debate are
they going to try and duck that too
uh why bother the mob of the media
they're already fawning over
kamala harris and of course they love
joe they don't call him out on anything
new york toilet paper times called her a
pragmatic
moderate that is another lie by the new
york toilet paper times
georgie stephanopoulos clinton hack
turned make-believe journalists over at
fake news abc
he's spreading the same bs take a look
kamala harris comes from the middle of
the road moderate wing of the democratic
uh party not the first choice of
progressives but joe biden
banking the this historic move as the
first woman of color on a national
ticket
will overcome that that's not true
either the mob in the media now 99
state-run democratic socialist fake news
but
yeah totally moderate that would be
except for her real
voting record 2019 for example
she's to the left of bolshevik bernie
sanders along with her vow to
oh yeah confiscate guns and via
executive fiat and order
and her support of oh yeah medicare for
all with zero chance of you having your
own health care provider
no choice i thought liberals were
pro-choice then her sponsorship
of the new green deal she was a
co-sponsor in the u.s senate
you know and the plan to ban fracking
pennsylvania
ohio michigan you watching this
limit by the way ban straws limit red
meat
that's all moderate sure i see georgie
hasn't changed since his days of trying
to bully reporters
into not publishing stories about bill
clinton's affairs
george stephanopoulos nothing but a
far-left political hack
masquerading as a journalist and abc
news
well they're not telling you the truth
and they're not alone naturally some of
kamala harris's biggest cheerleaders
they work for fake news cnn
and they're fake here's what their
vetting process looks like over there
take a look
i think she gave a very powerful speech
and if there is any doubt
that kamala harris is not going to be
able to go on the attack
as vice presidential candidates usually
do
that was erased today i thought akamal
harris gave a fantastic speech she
absolutely
unnailed it her ability i i think to
show this
this tremendous range a personal side of
her
look i mean it was a beautiful speech
both of them they strengthen each other
i think if you're going to give a
headline today it would be hope
reborn it's as though she was saying
them from the mountaintop
as opposed to you know just a high
school gymnasium there
and i think that the ease in which they
work together was very apparent
well because that's the exact opposite
when she only got what less than two
percent in the primary
and she did memorize her attack lines
well and she delivered them and
called joe biden pretty much a racist so
you got joe biden kamala harris they're
running for the highest office in the
land
yeah there would be critical questions
that the mob
needs to ask joe and kamala they've got
to answer
just today biden announced a plan to
impose a federal
mass mandate apparently he wants every
american wear a mask
any time you step outside of your home
now
i've been very outspoken i'm all for
americans voluntarily wearing mass
when it's crowded and you can't socially
distance
as a matter of fact i said anecdotally
it worked at the supermarket
i went through with the epicenter of all
this in the midst of the worst moments
in new york
not one person got corona or the rite
aid i would go to a cvs
because they had mass and plastic
anecdotally they work
and guess what what we're going to have
mass police next
what well next they say after operation
warp speed of president trump and
we're now in final stage trials for a
vaccine are we going to mandate that
i would say that's up to people to
decide they get to choose
will the byte administration be handing
out fines or arresting people don't
comply with their mandates that are
apparently universal are they universal
what about jogging outdoors
what about swimming in the ocean or on a
beach what about those who work outdoors
what about professional sports athletes
what does the first baseman have to
socially is that socially distant enough
from the second baseman or the shortstop
or third baseman
what about people eating at a restaurant
reading outdoors
any of these questions ever going to be
answered well even asked
now this is just one issue that must be
addressed in fact during the primaries
up it was senator harris raising
numerous serious concerns
i think she memorized her lines and
delivered him quite well when she
confronted
well the ever forgetful joe the corrupt
joe
about his work with segregationism
posing integration and so much more
we'll remind you on the hyde amendment
vice president
where you made a decision for years to
withhold resources
to poor women to have access to
reproductive health care
and including women who were the the
victims of rape and incest
do you now say that you have evolved and
you regret that because you've only
since you've been running for president
this time
i believe them and i i respect
them being able to tell their story and
having the courage to do it
do you believe that the vice president
should enter this race
oh he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself i wouldn't tell him what to
do the issue
of lynching is um
is part of the stain
um on america's history he apologized
this morning on twitter
um saying i should not have used those
words do you accept that apology
i i think that that's right for me to
apologize yes
you also worked with them to oppose
bussing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me wow
kamala has evolved election year
conversion i guess you might say also
kamala harris also believed joe biden's
accusers
apparently during the primary she
sympathized with all the women that
joe made really uncomfortable with this
creepy groping and touching
and hugging remember all this comma
i got hairy legs that turn that
that that that that turn uh um
blonde in the sun
[Music]
and the kids used to come up and reach
into the pool and rub my leg down
so it was straight and then watch the
hair come back
up again
[Music]
and we're not even showing you the
really creepy moments with younger
people
uh kamala did you forget about that
do you no longer care about this conduct
did you evolve as you say
uh i think you just used the words oh
yeah
uh evolving what about biden's work with
segregationists to slow school
integration
remember he worked with the former
klansmen the guy that actually
filibustered the historic civil rights
act and didn't support the voting rights
act
and guess what your bff partnered with
the former klansman because
joe biden didn't want his children to
grow up in a
racial jungle if his kids went to
integrated schools
you just no longer care that biden was
close to the former klansmen
praised the former klansmen worked with
the former plansman on
something like integration you talked
about that in that
debate moment you had with joe uh what
about principal
what about his comment you can't go to a
7-eleven or dunkin donuts unless you
have a slight indian accent
and i'm not joking he said what about
his recent comments suggesting that
african americans are
all the same or you ain't black or poor
kids or just as smart as white kids
okay really kamala is the mob in the
media you're going to ask these
questions
are you that desperate in this case to
be vice president of the united states
that
we'll just forget all about all this of
course this isn't just about senator
harris
it's about everyone in the mob in the
media they refuse to vet
joe biden we do we will do their job as
we always do
and today the president he answered
dozens of questions like he almost does
on a daily basis
from a hostile press corps a cult that
is psychotic in their hatred of
him so ask yourself why doesn't joe
biden
why doesn't kamala harris answer
questions where's their lengthy press
conference now my guess is
they're going to show up for a fluffy
interview on fake news cnn
they're going to show up on conspiracy
tv msdnc
that's where they'll show up probably
nowhere else are they going to show up
for the debates
are they not capable of the tough
questions go on with chris wallace
go on with well anybody
that will ask you a tough question
anyway what are they hiding
is it that they're radical how to touch
socialist positions
maybe is it joe biden's racist rhetoric
is it that kamala harris's terrible
record as a prosecutor
is it joe biden what was an obvious
well lack of strength and stamina and
mental acuity you know mental alertness
because i think the answer might be all
the above and in 82 days the american
people got to make an important choice
and before the first debate 16 states
begin early voting